[Musique]
info intox avec anthony st léger bonsoir
anthony bonsoir marion sort à tous avec
les récents cas de variole du singe les
thèses anti vaccins conspirationnistes
connu pendant l'épidémie de kobe de 19
serait active oui c'est un air de déjà
vu et comme pour le coc u19 et bien il
ya plusieurs variants figurez-vous l'un
d'entre eux celui de ce soir fait le
lien entre les deux maladies la variole
du singe serait une conséquence directe
de rein vaccin pour le enfin contre le
coc vie 19 explications avec cette
notice que l'on découvre ensemble est
plutôt un ingrédient l'adénovirus de
chimpanzés utilisé dans la prose dans le
processus de création du vaccin bingo la
suspicion s'éveille chez certains
internautes la boucle est bouclée le
lien entre les deux maladies est
clairement établie quelle coïncidence
note celui ci comment s'en étonner
seront renchérit même ce politicien
britannique parce que eh bien à l'image
du virus la propagation des de ce type
de théorie se fait à l'échelle mondiale
en français en anglais en allemand et en
portugais
la astrazeneca aurait donc provoqué
volontairement cette variole du singe la
variole est un des effets secondaires
d'astrazeneca peut-on lire ici et ce
twittos d'enfoncer cloud aussi celles
qui si c'était le cas pensez vous qu'on
nous le dire est alors qu'est ce qui est
vrai qu est ce qui est faux anthony et
bien oui et le vaccin astrazeneca
comporte bien un adénovirus du chimpanzé
c'est ce que nous explique par exemple
l' agence européenne des médicaments
c'est écrit ici mais non il n'y a pas de
lien entre la variole du singe et le
vaccin contre le coc vie 19 pourquoi
parce que d'une part cet adénovirus
cette fois c'est l'université d'oxford
qui nous l'expliquent a été
génétiquement modifiés et donc atténuée
pour ne pas être transmissible à l'homme
et ne pas se développer chez l'homme
ensuite la variole du singe est un poc
ce virus et non un adénovirus est ce que
nous rappelle l'inserm en clair c'est
comme si on comparait une fourmi avec un
rhinocéros ensuite la variole du singe
n'a pas grand chose à voir avec le singe
si ce n'est son nom parce qu'elle a été
découverte en rappel en 1958 au sein
d'un groupe de macaques mais là si elle
se développe chez l'homme se serait par
des animaux infectés et en l'occurrence
plutôt des rongeurs que des singes et
puis enfin l'adénovirus de chimpanzés a
déjà été utilisée bien avant qu vide
pour des vaccins contre la grippe
par exemple c'était en 2014 donc oui le
vaccin astrazeneca comporte bien de la
démo virus de chimpanzé mais ça n'a rien
à voir en tout cas c'est un établi aucun
lien entre le vaccin contre le coc u19
astrazeneca et cette épidémie de variole
du singe et cette épidémie corps et
annoncé notamment la série les simpson
voyez la série qui est souvent considéré
comme un oracle preuve en est selon
certains internautes et ce n'est pas que
du second degré ce dernier exemple du
jour avec ces trois images alors l'une
qui présente donc homer simpson aux
côtés à d'un singe on le voit ici il ya
cette autre à gauche qui fait de même et
puis sur les deux publications vous
voyez cette homer simpson recouvert de
boutons alors ça vient contredire ce que
je disais un puisque les singes ne sont
pas les animaux vecteur de cette variole
bref pour ce qui est des images elles
sont bien d'authentiqués n'ont pas été à
être rafic et mais elles ont été
associés les unes avec les hôtels n'ont
rien à voir explications retour donc sur
cette première image ici à gauche on la
retrouve ici dans cet épisode
21 de la saison 9 de la série au maire
adopte un singe dans le but de lui
apprendre les tâches ménagères un
peut-être que de boire une bière en fait
partie pour ce qui est de la deuxième on
le voit ici affalé sur un coussin et
bien on est dans la même saison dans le
même épisode quant à l'image de homer
recouvert de boutons et bien cette fois
c'est à l'épisode 3 de la saison 17 ici
la trappe en fait la varicelle après
avoir bu le biberon de sa fille rien à
voir donc avec la variole du singe
encore une fois mais c'est vrai que le
dessin animé se voit a régulièrement à
titre et finalement cette capacité à
anticiper des événements des
infirmations qui sont souvent des
enfants que ça leur soit avec des images
montées de toutes pièces soient aussi
comme c'est le cas ce soir avec à des
vraies images mais faussement associés
je vous rends se voit d'ailleurs à cet
épisode daf ont un coach pour en savoir
plus mais aussi des prévisions qui
parfois se réalise puisqu'il avait
prédit l'élection de donald trump et ça
c'était une réalité eh bien on vous
invite à revoir donc cette étude
d'informa tox sur internet fait par les
observateurs merci beaucoup anthony pour
ce point info intox rester avec nous
prochain rendez vous dans dans une
quelques minutes
[Musique]